it's lunchtime but at this elementary
school most of ignore can't eat or drink
water even though it's one of the
hottest days all year because they are
fasting my mother wakes me up at 2:00 in
the morning then I'm allowed to eat the
exact time changes there's an extra
calendar for that and I can eat till
3:00 a.m. it's okay to eat at that time
then I go back to sleep it's not that
bad because I don't get that hungry most
of the children in this Berlin school
come from Muslim families not all of
them are strict when it comes to obeying
the rules of Ramadan in the middle of
the night you wake up and you eat as
much as you can then your stomach
stretches because it's full and the next
day it constricts and that's bad for
your health
that's why I think fasting is not a good
idea I fasted at school in the past but
my mom told me if it's too hot and the
sun is shining brightly then I should
stop fasting I only fast in the weekends
because if I do it while I'm at school I
can't concentrate I fall asleep school
principal Astrid Sabina busa observes
that in the last few years an increasing
number of very young students take the
Muslim rule of fasting very seriously I
don't know of any other religious
community that considers itself so
important that the school has to change
its schedule to suit them for me this is
a no-go religion is something very
private
we have religious freedom in Germany but
we can't reorganize the school system to
enable it the school is in the Berlin
district of Noah cone where a lot of
Muslims live here opinion on whether
children should fast is divided if it's
voluntary it's fine but if they're
forced to do it now if they're convinced
then it's okay kids are entitled to an
opinion - it would be better for
children if they stayed at home during
Ramadan in Germany staying home is not
an option because schooling is mandatory
and noren mustafa have to perform the
same tasks as their classmates who are
not
fasting I don't have any problems with
this I'm just thirsty sometimes my
mother always says if I can't go on then
it's okay to drink or eat something then
I just have to break my fast Mustafa is
lucky he can fast without being put
under pressure there are no clear rules
in Islam concerning at what age children
must begin fasting
[Music]